the city council of Oakland voted 80 to
call for a ceasefire one city council
member then tried to insert language in
it at least to just condemn Hamas now I
want to show you the reaction of some of
the Oakland citizens when all they
wanted to put in to the thing they were
going to call for a ceasefire no matter
what was just a little mild condemnation
of the terror group Hamas calling Hamas
a terrorist organization is ridiculous
racist and plays into genocidal
propaganda that is flooding our media
and that we should be doing everything
possible to combat as an Arab asking
with this context to condemn Hamas is
very anti-arab racist to hear them
complain about Hamas violence is like
listening to a wife beeter complain when
his wife finally stands up and fights
back question did anyone else notice
that those who oppose this resolution
are old white supremacists what bro what
are you talking about man